the 18 alleged co-conspirators mostly
his attorneys like Jenna Ellis Rudy
Giuliani and John Eastman who was the
intellectual architect of that elector
scheme that Mike Pence rejected um it's
a scheme that was laid out in this
Sixpoint memo that was released um I've
highlighted a couple sections of this
including one aspect is that Pence would
gavel in Trump uh as real elected
after um kind of rejecting one slate of
electors for another and then Force the
other side to fight to to fight to fight
it out in court so going on a sort of
offense and point six here he says the
main thing here is that Pence should do
this without asking for permission
either from a vote of the joint session
or from the court let the other side
challenge his actions in court Eastman
recently appeared he appeared last week
on Laura anging show on Fox and this is
what he had to say in his
defense you know the people that I was
representing had a right to counsel and
what's going on here with the Bar
complaints against everybody involved in
any of the litigation this Fulton County
complaint the unindicted co-conspirators
and the federal action they're trying to
stifle people from being able to get
representation in election challenges if
if disputed question of constitutional
law all of a sudden become criminal we
we could we could uh throw you know the
entire legal profession the entire legal
Academy in in jail the fact of the
matter is throughout our history uh
significant uh leaders in Congress have
have argued that Congress doesn't have
Authority Under the 12th Amendment that
the founder specifically designed it
that way so that the president wouldn't
owe his job to Congress it's a core
separation of powers principle that the
founders adopted and he just doesn't he
ignores that uh in his analysis so the
notion that this is well settled is
crazy is bringing the attorneys into
this case criminalizing dissent and
criminalizing
the profession of law as isman suggests
here Ilia in a word no uh because what
Eastman and some of the others were
doing here went beyond simply giving
legal advice it was particip ating in
urging a scheme of illegal conduct in
this case as You's highed in that memo
trying to get pens to illegally reject
the electoral votes uh and the like and
there's many cases involving Mafia
lawyers for example where when the
lawyer doesn't merely advise his client
and sort of how to defend himself in
court or something like that but instead
uh you know participates in a scheme for
for illegal action you know lawyers can
be prosecuted for that and this is far
from the first time uh that this has has
happened to be sure there can be cases
where there's gray areas as with many
legal doctrines in this case with
Eastman and so on the others I don't
think it's that much for gray area
because Eastman was clearly urging the
specific plan uh that was uh adopted
here uh he wasn't me even merely saying
like you know somebody else wanted Tuda
plan and they asked Eastman whether it
would be legal or not uh you know
Eastman went beyond you know something
uh like that so uh if
uh you know a mafia lawyer advises uh
his you know his Mafia client that you
know we should we should kill this
person and not only that but it would be
legal to kill him because it would just
be self-defense or something like that
uh you know the mafia lawyer could be
prosecuted for that and he couldn't hide
behind you know the idea that he was
just giving legal advice uh that you the
planning of future crimes uh is one of
the uh standard exceptions to attorney
client privil
and one of the kinds of things that
historically Warriors can be and have
been prosecuted for when they engage in
it okay but isn't that kind of an
extreme metaphor you know he he wasn't
uh uh advocating anyone be killed he his
argument is that this is a legitimate uh
contested area of constitutional
interpretation you you just agree you
just disagree that this is in any way a
valid way to interpret the Constitution
so his argument was extremely bad but uh
this is going Beyond merely making a bad
argument in the abstract this is urging
a specific course of action and planning
it out uh and uh I don't think it's at
the comparisons to Mafia is all that
extreme when you recognize the dire
horrible consequences of what would have
happened if this scheme had succeeded
that is that a president would have been
able to stay in power despite losing
election uh that's you not exactly the
same thing as as carrying out of murder
uh but it's nonetheless a large scale
awful
crime one of the things that worries me
a little bit about the sort of sedici
seditious conspiracy wrapper around this
is how far that can be extended I mean
we're already we're roping in attorneys
who are advancing these legal theories
or courses of action um you know the the
Sedition charge has been used to
prosecute and sentence to decades in
prison actually know there is no
sedition charge in any of these
cases okay that there's a cons but it
okay so there's a conspiracy charge
there's a there's the RICO charge okay
and then we can say that you know the
Sedition charge is a
separate charge that's been uh applied
to the the January 6 rioter um who are
now some of them are facing decades in
prison some some who were not even there
I I'm I'm worried that this approach
this expansive approach is handing
unbounded power to suppress descent to
whichever party controls the state
should I be worried about that uh I
think in this particular set of cases no
uh when you talk about the January 6
people yes some of them weren't there
but those who weren't there were ones
who were involved in the planning of the
attack on the capital they weren't
merely people who just said the election
was illegitimate or that Trump really
wenton and the like they were leaders of
organizations like the oathkeepers and
the proud boys who were directly
involved in the planning of the attack
so if you're involved in a planning of a
violent action uh you can certainly be
charged with that uh even if you weren't
personally present there uh and uh on
the uh breath of a conspiracy you know
as I said before I'm not an expert on
Rico uh but uh when you're looking at
people like East these were people who
were in the Inner Circle of plan manners
specifically planning out the specific
actions regarding fake collectors uh
rejecting the uh the the plan to have
Trump reject the ballots and reject the
electoral votes and so forth so these
are not people with some far out
indirect connection to the plan these
were essentially the planners themselves
uh in the Georgia case admittedly I'm
not in I'm not familiar with all the
details of all the indictments of the 18
different people so perhaps you can find
someone among the 18 who was much
further removed than Eastman and if so
we can talk about whether you know it's
a good idea to charge that person or not
but with someone like Eastman and other
uh people closely involved in the
planning I think you know there's no
great Swip res Swope risk indeed there's
a Swip PR Swope risk the other way if
you let PE these people get off simply
because their lawyers are the like uh
because then that creates an obvious
incentive to use lawyers to uh plan your
uh schemes to uh stay in power hey
thanks for watching that clip from our
conversation with ilas San about the
Trump indictments for another clip go
right here for the full conversation
click here